partisan mais il s'agit des députés nous
sommes au sénat or le sénat occupe une
position complètement différente
c'est ce dont convenait l'adversaire le
plus persuasif le plus éloquent du cumul
des mandats je veux dire mon ami
carcassonne qui réservait au sénat une
position une situation différente
représenter une nation 10 et il s'est
représenté une population mais aussi
représenter un territoire
or une assemblée unique procède
malaisément à cette double
représentation et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'étais un des hommes des
arguments ce n'est pas le seul mais
c'est un des arguments en faveur du
bicamérisme une assemblée principalement
la population une assemblée
principalement le territoire certes on
ne peut pas séparer entièrement ces deux
représentations de balai dissocier
totalement mais l'important c'est
dirais-je la mission constitutionnelle
qui est assignée à chacune des deux
chambres
pour ce qui est des députés la priorité
est évidemment attribué à la population
avec correctifs démographique ne peuvent
pas encore le type géographique en
correctif territoriales qui peut
évidemment varier selon les modes de
scrutin suivant c'est un scrutin
uninominal ou un scrutin de liste en
revanche pour les sénateurs l'article 24
nous connaissons tous fixe au sénat la
mission de représenter les collectivités
territoriales de la république
c'est donc la priorité
qui est donnée à cette représentation
des collectivités territoriales avec
évidemment un correctif
ce sont les critères démographiques que
rappelle la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel
il en résulte un caractère résultat le
dirait un lien organique entre le sénat
et les collectivités territoriales dont
il est l'émanation
bref élus par les citoyens
le député se définit d'abord comme un
citoyen le sénateur élu par les élus
territoriaux
s'il n'est pas nécessairement l'un
d'entre eux est logiquement amené à être
l'un d'entre eux
car cela traduit cette relation ce lien
organique qui est assignée par l'article
24 de la constitution mais cela est si
vrai cela est si vrai que guy
carcassonne précisément pour le citer
dans ses propositions de réforme du
sénat
celle qui l'avait qui avait ses
préférences et es2 d'attribuer la moitié
des sièges du sénat aux maires des
grandes villes aux présidents des
conseils généraux et des conseils
régionaux le reste étant élu comme
d'habitude c'est dire que le dans son
esprit
l'hostilité au cumul des mandats au
cumul des fonctions précisément concerné
essentiellement l'assemblée nationale
est épargné le sénat 6e
lorsque l'on sic lorsque l'on invoque
une autorité comme la sienne
il est honnête d'aller jusqu'au bout de
ne pas la tronquer cela dit je
terminerai le président et par une note
stratégique dans l'économie du
bicamérisme et dans le dialogue des deux
assemblées
il n'est pas douteux que l'interdiction
du cumul des fonctions qui s'impose aux
députés il n'est pas douteux que cela
apporterait au sénat un surcroît de
dynamisme et d'autorité ne serait ce qu
en y attirant les élus locaux qui aspire
à une carrière politique nationale et
ajouteraient jeu les députés qui
entendent la poursuivre sans renoncer
pour autant à leurs fonctions locales je
vous remercie monsieur le président
merci monsieur le professeur pire avril
peuvent se donne immédiatement la parole
à madame la professeure julie benetti
madame le professeur ou la professeure
s'est passé
le professeur madame le professeur très
bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
c'est un plaisir et un honneur d'être
entendu par votre commission même s'il
ne met pas facile de m'exprimer après le
professeur pierre avril dont les travaux
ont profondément marqué mon travail de
thèse et chose inédite pour une fois je
vais me démarquer de ses positions sur
le cumul cumul des mandats c'est un
sujet dont nous avons longuement
débattue au sein de la commission
présidée par monsieur lionel jospin vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le président et
je voudrais si vous me permettez rappelé
à titre liminaire qu'elle a été l'esprit
de nos propositions sur ce sujet
le fil rouge qui a guidé notre réflexion
c'est la volonté de renforcer le lien
unissant les citoyens à leurs
représentants de cette exigence ont
découlé toutes les propositions de notre
rapport et en particulier celle de
limiter strictement le cumul des mandats
des parlementaires et sur cet objectif
je dois dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de
dissensions au sein de la commission
jospin dont certains membres
souhaitaient même le passage immédiat au
mandat parlementaire unique
la commission a finalement jugé opportun
de ne pas recommander d'emblée
l'interdiction pour un parlementaire
d'exercer tout mandat local pour autant
nos préconisations s'inscrivent
clairement dans cette perspective d'une
évolution rapide vers le mandat
parlementaire unique car en dépit des
réformes de 1985 et 2000
la pratique du cumul reste très répandue
en france et il nous a donc semblé que
le temps n'était plus aux réformes est
mais au passage à l'acte il faut des
mesures fortes pour rentrer sans
ambiguïté avec l'état du droit et des
pratiques
d'où notre proposition de rendre
incompatibles le mandat parlementaire
avec tout mandat électif
autre qu'un mandat de simple conseiller
local et que cette nouvelle
incompatibilité inclus dans son champ
les fonctions locales dites dérivés
c'est à dire toutes les fonctions même
d'un exécutive qui peuvent être exercés
ès qualité par des élus locaux au sein
d'établissements locaux dont les
pouvoirs et les moyens sont souvent
sensiblement supérieurs à ceux des
collectivités territoriales elle même le
projet de loi organique initial était en
retrait par rapport à nos préconisations
puisque pour l'essentiel n'était visé
que les fonctions exécutives des
collectivités territoriales ainsi que
celle des établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale mais
uniquement à fiscalité propre
mais à l'initiative du rapporteur la
discussion luis borges elle la
discussion a été mise à profit l
assemblée nationale pour élargir le
périmètre de cette incompatibilité et y
inclure les fonctions exécutives des
syndicats intercommunaux et des
syndicats mixtes ainsi que les fonctions
de président de vice président et de
membre de conseil d'administration des
établissements publics locaux des
sociétés d'économie mixte locale des
sociétés publiques locales ou des
organismes de hlm
d'ailleurs il faudrait sans doute
modifier l'intitulé même de la loi dès
lors que ne sont pas seulement visé ici
des fonctions exécutives
mais j'en viens au point sans doute le
plus délicat
le projet de loi organique s'accordent
avec le rapport de la commission jospin
pour écarter l'idée d'un traitement
différencié entre députés et sénateurs
d'abord et il faut ici être très clair
l'article 24 de la constitution que vous
rappeler monsieur le professeur avril
selon lequel le sénat assure la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république
cet article 24 n'impliquent en aucune
façon que les sénateurs soit des élus
locaux mais seulement qu'il soit élu par
un collège composé essentiellement
d'élus locaux
au demeurant les sénateurs pourraient
conserver un mandat local
même après l'adoption du projet de loi
organique et continuer de siéger dans
les conseils municipaux départementaux
et régionaux
il me semble pas qu'il faille
nécessairement détenir un mandat
exécutif local pour être un élu local
ensuite et j'insiste sur ce point la
constitution ne fait aucune différence
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
s'agissant des missions du parlement il
ne s'agit pas de nier la spécificité du
sénat
mais mesdames messieurs les sénateurs à
trop vouloir creuser cette spécificité
sénatoriales vous pourriez aussi ouvrir
la voie à une transformation du sénat en
une chambre des territoires et qui comme
telle verrait ses prérogatives diminuer
par rapport à celle de l'assemblée
nationale car derrière la question du
cumul des mandats se profile se joue
aussi le devenir du sénat si la
spécificité sénatoriales justifiait
aujourd'hui de traiter différemment
députés et sénateurs
quant au cumul des mandats elle
pourraient demain tout aussi bien
justifier de traiter différemment
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat quant
à leurs prérogatives
autrement dit si je plaide à titre
personnel pour que les sénateurs soient
traités comme les députés c'est que je
considère les uns et les autres comme
des parlementaires à part entière
je comprends bien les inquiétudes de
certains élus face à ces préconisations
face aux recommandations de la
commission jospin qui ont inspiré le
projet de loi organique dont vous allez
débattre mais jamais nos propositions
n'ont été dirigées contre les
parlementaires que nous aurions voulu
coupé des réalités locales de leur
territoire au nom de je ne sais quel
dogg lou lubie d'universitaires notre
souci c'est la rénovation du parlement
et notre conviction au sein de la
commission a été que le cumul est un
frein un obstacle puissant à la
revalorisation de la fonction
parlementaire comme du reste au plein
exercice des fonctions exécutives
locales
les parlementaires doivent se consacrer
entièrement à leurs fonctions de
parlementaire c'est à ce prix celui de
la disponibilité des parlementaires et
là aussi je souhaiterais rappeler les
écrits les nombreux écrits de guy
carcassonne sur ce sujet c'est au prix
la disponibilité des parlementaires pour
se saisir des prérogatives qui sont les
leurs et qui sont nombreux spécialement
depuis la révision de 2008 que la
rénovation du parlement cessera d'être
un vieux pieux et pourra devenir
effective car c'est aux gouvernements et
aux responsables des groupes que profite
in fine et le cumul des mandats pas au
parlement
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame le professeur me julie
benetti pour votre exposé je vois que
dans deux exposés aboutissent à des
conclusions différentes
notre ami parce que pour beaucoup
d'entre nous c'est un ami guy
carcassonne s'est illustré que nous en
sommes heureux même si nous avons été
triste de le perdre
alors monsieur le professeur dominique
rousseau
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur la porter mesdames messieurs à
mon tour de vous remercier de votre
invitation c'est évidemment toujours un
honneur d'être reçu par la
représentation nationale
même si et on en a déjà vu et peut-être
un aperçu même si les débats concernant
le cumul des mandats et est un débat
récurrent connu où tous les arguments
sont sur la table depuis longtemps en
faveur du cumul c'est la proximité avec
le citoyen l'ancrage territorial donner
de l'autonomie aux parlementaires à
l'égard des partis politiques contre le
cumul c'est l'idée que le parlement a
depuis 2008
retrouvez des pouvoirs importants et
qu'il convient par conséquent que les
parlementaires soient uniquement
consacré à leur tâche de législateurs de
contrôleurs du gouvernement d'évaluation
des politiques publiques contre le cumul
aussi l'idée de nécessité de rénover la
vie politique de l'ouvrir à d'autres à
d'autres catégories
donc le débat est connu et finalement
maintenant il s'agirait de le trancher
politiquement et là un universitaire n'a
rien à dire
c'est à vous de dire nous sommes nous
sommes pas en tous les cas pour ce qui
me concerne ne sommes pas élus et vous
vous avez une connaissance du terrain de
la vie de parlementaire que nous n'avons
pas et nous pouvons seulement donner des
indications des observations que l'on
tient soit des discussions qu'on a pu
avoir avec des parlementaires soient des
expériences de
de droit comparé mais l'essentiel
maintenant est entre vos mains vous
connaissez les arguments je voudrais
simplement faire trois assists et sur 3
3.2.2 politique constitutionnelle n'est
pas de droit constitutionnel et puis un
point peut-être de contentieux
constitutionnel sur les points de
politiques constitutionnelles
je pense que il y à un premier point
important qui est celui de la conception
que l'on peut se faire du mandat
politique en général vous savez quand en
sciences politiques certaines bien les
comparaisons notamment avec le
l'économie et le marché
alors on peut cumuler les mandats ville
canton département nation région on peut
un peu au monopoly acheter tous les tous
les secteurs en rouge tous les secteurs
orange et puis on accumule du capital et
après éventuellement on peut le le cd
céder des parts de marché on sait d'une
ville compte une région entre un
département pour ma part je suis plutôt
favorable à la distribution du capital
politique car l'accumulation
monopolistique du capital politique
d'ailleurs comme du capital economics
suis je pas favorables au régime
capitaliste matière économique et pas
davantage en matière politique je pense
que la distribution du capital politique
me paraît être plus favorable à une
respiration du jeu politique
même si c'est introduit de la
concurrence mais c'est comment dire un
élément important de
de d'énergie démocratique pour pour un
pays
deuxième point de politiques
constitutionnelles après cette idée de
distribution d'accumulation du capital
une discussion sur le fait de ne pas
concevoir la question du cumul des
mandats de manière isolée
je ne crois pas du tout il ya une
expression célèbre du président chirac
je ne reprendrai pas ici évidemment mais
je pense que lorsqu'on touche un article
de la constitution
on touche tous les autres et qu'il n'y a
pas de réforme le quinquennat sec est
une et ça ça ne veut rien dire
touché la durée du mandat présidentiel
vous touchez la fonction du premier
ministre vous touchez la fonction des
parlementaires me touche et la manière
dont on élit les députés et trois
semaines trois semaines après donc il
faut concevoir me semble-t-il la
question du cumul non pas en tant que
tel mais en la reliant avec d'autres
éléments qui font système par exemple on
ne peut pas me semble-t-il réfléchir à
la réforme du cumul des mandats sans
entamer une discussion sur le statut du
parlementaire si on interdit un
parlementaire de cumuler ce mandat de
parlementaire avec des avec des
fonctions exécutives is me faut à ce
moment-là prévoit d'augmenter
l'indemnité parlementaire
il faut à ce moment-là prévoir de donner
aux parlementaires les moyens matériels
humains financiers afin d'exercer
convenablement son mandat
si on si on interdit le cumul des
mandats il faut évidemment revaloriser
mais de manière réelle effective les
pouvoirs du parlement
si on demande aux parlementaires de
légiférer de contrôler le gouvernement
man il fillon lui demandait à paris il
faut qu'à paris il est des choses à
faire et par conséquent on ne peut pas
concevoir la question du cumul des
mandats sans le relier au pouvoir du au
pouvoir du parlement et jean vient
évidemment à la relation de
l'interdiction éventuelle du cumul des
mandats par rapport à chaque assemblée
et là je vais reprendre le débat avec
avec julie avec leur soeur julie benetti
débat qu'on a eu au sein de la
commission jospin qui me fait être
partisan je les écris dans l'opinion
séparé publié à la fin du rapport jospin
je suis partisan d'une interdiction
totale pour les députés et je suis
partisan d'une obligation du cumul pour
les sénateurs je pense que l'article 24
et l'article 25 sont les bases possibles
je reconnais que l'argumentation de de
julie et de pierres sont tout à fait
recevable et convenable je considère que
le le sénat n'a de légitimité
excusez-moi jeunes est clair le sénat
n'a de légitimité dans une république
que s'il n'est pas le doublon de
l'assemblée nationale et la question de
la légitimité du sénat qui est
récurrente qui est récurrente viennent
du fait que s qui représente les
citoyens à ce moment la concurrence avec
le concurrence avec l'assemblée
nationale alors on dit oui mais on peut
être sénateur à 40 ans puis à 35 4 etc
ont modifié le mode d'élection est ce
que le sénat représente et territoires
où il m'a alors
l'assemblée nationale je pense que le
l'assise du sénat dans nos institutions
ne sera pas sécurisé et garanti tant
qu'on ne recollera qu'on ne reconnaîtra
pas au sénat sa qualité d'assemblée
représentant les collectivités
territoriales et cette représentation se
fait non seulement par le collège
électoral mais également par les membres
composant cette assemblée pour être
sénateur c'est à dire pour représenter
les collectivités territoriales article
il faut soi-même être un représentant
des collectivités territoriales mère
prise en conseil général présente le col
de conseil régional
alors je dis que c'est un élément de
politique constitutionnelle dans la
mesure où ma réflexion centre non
seulement dans la réalité actuelle mais
dans une dynamique étant favorable est
temps favorable sur le plan
constitutionnel à une décentralisation
poussée pour rester dans un langage
sophistiqués je pense qu'il ne pourra y
avoir de véritable art régionalisation
que lorsqu'il y aura une classe
politique régionale autonome différente
de la classe politique nationale
deuxièmement je pense que la logique
institutionnelle et de développer les
pouvoirs des régions des communautés des
grandes villes peu importe
et que par conséquent et il sera
nécessaire que le poids politique des
collectivités décentralisées comme une
région agglo ben port puisse avoir une
expression institutionnel la somme et
nationales représentent les citoyens le
sénat représente les collectivités
territoriales et ensemble ils
représentent la nation
ensemble ils représentent la nation
mais le sénat n'est pas un doublon plus
ou moins plus ou moins correct de
l'assemblée de l'assemblée nationale et
c'est en ce sens que j'ai soutenu l'idée
de permettre aux sénateurs de cumuler
leur mandat parlementaire avec un mandat
d'exécutif local
j'allais même dans nos discussions
jusqu'à en faire une obligation mais la
permission de cumuler me conviendrait
très bien
dernier point si vous permettez
peut-être alors cette fois de
contentieux constitutionnel puisque
c'est un point qui a fait débat celui
sur le la date d'entrée en vigueur de la
réforme alors là aussi on a tout entendu
au fil de l'eau en fonction des
élections 2017 2014
la question de la date d'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme renvoi par
ricochet à la question des des
suppléants puisque pour éviter les
élections législatives partielles il
conviendrait de modifier la loi
organique qui étendrait les hypothèses
de remplacement du parlementaire par son
suppléant est la question qui se pose
est de savoir si le conseil
constitutionnel accepterait que soit
modifié en cours de mandat le
le statut le régime juridique des
parlementaires et de et des suppléants
alors évidemment le toujours très
difficile de prévoir ce que va dire le
conseil constitutionnel il ya quand même
quelques décisions et notamment une
décision du 6 juin 2013
donc tu aurais toute récente qui montre
que le conseil constitutionnel admet il
s'agissait de de proroger la durée d'un
mandat et d'abroger la durée d'un mandat
le conseil constitutionnel admet qu'on
puisse modifier en cours de mandat le
régime juridique du parlementaire pour
un motif d'intérêt général et le conseil
constitutionnel accepte que la nécessité
de faire rapidement entrer en vigueur
une réforme soit constitutifs d'un
intérêt général
je reconnais et j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire je reconnais que la sécurité
juridique absolue c'est de mettre le
début de la réforme en 2010 est là il y
a évidemment aucun risque
mettre la réforme en 2014 c'est à dire
avant les élections municipales comporte
un risque de censure par le conseil
constitutionnel
à mon sens un risque minime dans la
mesure où
premièrement le conseil constitutionnel
dans toutes ces affaires là répète
régulièrement qui ne dispose pas d'un
pouvoir général de décision et
d'appréciation identique à celui du
parlement et que le conseil est très
réservé à rentrer dans les affaires
internes de l'assemblée nationale du
sénat et qu'encore une fois il a accepté
que pour des raisons d'entrer en vigueur
rapide d'une réforme
cette réforme puisse rentrer en
application en cours de mandat voilà
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs c'est
quelques observations que je vous ai
livré à votre réflexion
dit monsieur le professeur dominique
rousseau et je vais maintenant donner la
parole aux dernières orateurs n'ont pas
inscrit mais qui nous fait l'honneur
d'être avec nous monsieur le professeur
olivier baud merci le président monsieur
le président merci sur à porter mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je vais être
s'il est synthétique pour illustrer une
thèse qui a déjà défendu pire avery
c'est à dire une thèse relativement
hostile au projet actuel de réforme
la raison pour laquelle je me suis
engagé dans cette voie ce combat mais en
tout cas dans cette contestation de la
réforme tient à deux éléments le premier
élément c'est la lecture du rapport
jospin qui sur ce point précis m'a assez
hérité en raison du goût dogmatisme
assez nette des propos défendu par la
commission c'est à dire dogmatisme
consistant à dire que le mal absolu
c'était le cumul des mandats et que le
remède bien raide sa suppression de la
limitation et à l'occasion donc de
l'écriture d'un commentaire de ce
rapport j'ai un peu commencé à réfléchir
à cette question alors même qu'au début
j'étais plutôt favorable à la
suppression du cumul des mandats j'étais
assez proches et des tests de guy
carcassonne
en tout cas concernant l'assemblée
nationale puis la deuxième raison c'est
l'article que m'avait envoyé et patrick
weil concernant justement ce que les
mandats est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
signé avec pierre avril et laurent
bouvet cette lettre ouverte ou venant à
lui la raison principale fondamentale
pour laquelle je suis relativement
hostile au projet tel qu'il est en tout
cas conçu c'est qu'il va aggraver la
présidentialisation c'est à dire c'est
un rhume argument très réaliste le
rapporteur monsieur borgel a dit que
c'est un argument rustique mais je
partage pas son opinion évidemment c'est
un argument réaliste ça consiste à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a une présence et
présidentialisation de plus en plus
nettes sont plus affirmée une
concentration de plus en plus tendue et
dangereuse des pouvoirs au profit du
président quel que soit évidemment
l'appartenance politique du président et
qui a en france très peu de contre
pouvoirs et me semble qu un
contre-pouvoir qui existaient qui mérite
d'exister encore c'est effectivement
l'existence au sein du parlement de
grands barons de grands féodaux alors
évidemment c'est pas du tout glorieux
comme argument c'est un argument très
réaliste qui consiste à dire que pour
essayer de lutter contre l'omnipotence
du président il lui faut des adversaires
avant adversaires potentiels c'était
éventuellement même appartenant à sa
propre majorité pour éviter au président
d'airé de faire des erreurs parce que
comme tout homme le président est
faillible et donc il m'a semblé que le
projet était dangereux en raison
fondamentale mans de cette affaire qui
évidemment n'est pas lié directement à
la question du statut des parlementaires
qui concerne l'équilibré global
l'institution et c'est je crois le
constat qu'on a fait ensemble notamment
est bien arrivé ça c'est la raison si
vous et pour moi en tout cas là la plus
importante qui n'apparaît pas beaucoup
d'air dans les débats parlementaires
ça c'est le première chose que je
voulais expliquer la deuxième chose que
je veux expliquer c'est l'impression que
m'ont donné les débats parlementaires
les débats la semaine nationale qui sont
assez riches d'ailleurs puisque
l'université en général disent assez peu
et débat parlementaire sera pas le temps
il faut que j'ai pris le temps de les
lire et je tenais à saluer la qualité
des interventions que ce soit en
commission ou lors des débats qu'est-ce
qu'on a pris c'est qu'est ce que nous a
appris en tout cas ces débats mois après
plusieurs choses après la chose c'est
skate de leurs professeurs benetti c'est
à dire une extension une sorte de
logique infernale d'extension des
incompatibilités vers l'opposition s'est
amusé à ajouter des des amendements pour
confirmer cette logique de l'absurde
donc on voit les incompatibilités
s'étendre considérablement en tout cas
c'est tendre effectivement impressionné
tu y as raison ou pour échanger le titre
même du projet de loi
et puis deuxième chose qui m'a frappé
c'est d'abord la porte et on dit c'est
le cumul des mandats mais là il me
semble qu'il ya un glissement ou un sou
très important qu'il faut noter c'est on
passe d'une limite logique de limitation
à une logique d'interdiction de
prohibition
le terme même de projet de loi c
interdisant est donc là il ya enlevé un
saut qualitatif qui n'a pas du tout à
mon avis était suffisamment mise en
valeur par les commentateurs on passe
d'une limitation ce qu'effectivement une
mutation à une sorte de liberté à une
interdiction et la ja on a vu un
changement
capital qui méritent de noter les
troisièmes chose que j'ai appris en
lisant ces débats parlementaires c'est
que beaucoup de députés y compris des
députés socialistes ont énormément de
réserve à l'égard de la réforme je veux
citer juste un exemple parce que là
plusieurs mais c'est le député au jeu je
ne connaissais pas mais qui a fait un
très bonne intervention de monsieur
david habib
c'est à la séance il intéresse des 4
juillet 2013 voici ce que dit monsieur
habib la fin du cumul
si elle n'est pas accompagnée d'un vaste
mouvement décentralisateur renforcera
paris et l'échelon central par rapport à
la province
je vous ai entendu évoqué hier monsieur
le ministre avec beaucoup de fougue et
de talence et commune administrée par
des maires de qualité qui ne sont pas
parlementaires vous avez cité
montpellier toulouse lille or vous le
savez le problème ne concerne pas ces
communes les agglomérations et les
villes moyennes qui ont besoin d'un
relais avec question centrale
je crains je le répète ici je suis
toujours le député habib que la fin du
cumul soit pour celle ci un élément
déstabilisateur
fin de citation j'ai pris cette citation
parmi d'autres l'on pourrait multiplier
les citations de députés qui ont des
réserves très importantes et évidemment
ils ont désarmé vont voter ils ont voté
en faveur du projet de loi parce
qu'évidemment majorité oblige et bien
ils doivent obéir et c'est la fameuse
cas polarisation caporalisation sa part
les pierreries et j'en arrive à la
dernière remarque que ça dans ces débats
et le rapport donc monsieur mangel me
sens que tout à l'heure face à rousseau
a très justement parlé de la question la
conception construit du mandat politique
et là il me semble que la deuxième
grands enjeux de cette réforme c'est
qu'est ce qu'on veut comme élu dans
notre république
et bien la réponse en tout cas telle
qu'elle se dessine dans le rapport
borgel eh bien les données par
rapporteur lorsque il évoque la question
du remplacement des parlementaires qui
va être un remplacement cette fois-ci
automatiques sont plus difficiles y au
total cette réforme du régime du
remplacement des députés des sénateurs
élus au scrutin majoritaire renforce
notablement l'importance du suppléant et
corrélativement atténue la dimension
personnelle de l'élection une telle
évolution prend acte de ce que
lorsqu'ils se rendent aux urnes les
électeurs choisissent non seulement une
personnalité chargée de représenter
parlement mais aussi une majorité
politique ayant vocation à gouverner
pendant tout un mandat fin de citation
dans le rapport borgel page 31
ce qui veut bien dire à propos de cette
affaire qui paraît secondaire du
remplacement pour dire ce qui est
important c'est la question de
l'interdiction du cumul mais évidemment
il ya le corollaire comment remplacer ce
qui deviendra team on a très bien ici
que le rapporteur dit en quelque sorte
la vérité de cette réforme c'est à dire
qu'il faut renforcer l'allégeance
partisane éclat ya évidemment un débat
sur la démocratie
comment est-ce qu'on conçoit le mandat
politique comment conçoit ce mandat et
là évidemment c'est une opinion si je
pouvais coup droit mon opinion le micro
soucier de la politique au ciel mon
opinion c'est que le point fondamental
dans une démocratie c'est que les
lecteurs soient capables de contrôler
celui qui le connaissent tout simplement
parce que s'ils connaissent ont élus eh
bien il a des chances de pouvoir évaluer
sa politique de pouvoir le contester
éventuellement de pouvoir remettre en
cause ce moment là et on a vu cet
argument était constamment utilisé par
les opposants cette réforme était de
droite mais je pense que certaines
gauche le partage c'est à dire qu'il ya
une logique très forte qui consiste à
dire soit on fait confiance aux
électeurs qu'ils élisent leurs élus et
leurs députés
soit on fait confiance aux partis qui va
s'arranger pour promouvoir des carrières
uniquement politique dès l'âge de 20 ans
comme je suis universitaire et je
souffre terriblement de la politique
menée à l'université en raison du poids
déterminant de l'unef ou nous
permettrait de faire allusion à certains
députés ou sénateurs qui n'ont connu que
la vie politique qui ont été militant à
18 ans et qui finissent députés ou
sénateurs à 60 ans sans avoir jamais
rien connu de la société civile et bien
c'est ça mon avis ça le débat
fondamental que pose cette réforme et
c'est pour ça qu'elle est capital elle
est effectivement du cirque manière
d'une nature constitutionnelle et je
finirai par un dernier élément puisque
c'est au sénat
tout ce que j'ai dit à propos de cette
réforme qui à mon avis milite contre
cette réforme vaud a fortiori pour le
sénat et je vais pas être très longue
puisque denis rousseau vient de faire la
démonstration dans ses derniers propos
sur le fait qu'on ne doit pas identifié
le sénat effectivement juridiquement il
ya une sorte de bizarreries qui m'a
adhère aussi étonné parce que j'avais
jamais réfléchi mais là j'ai réfléchi
c'est qu'il n'ya pas de différence de
statut juridique entre l'ain compatible
incompatibilité du député
l'incompatibilité du sénateur
c'est tout le monde à hazard historique
l'ordonance de 58 très mal rédigé
puisqu'il dit les incompatibilités sont
applicables aux sénateurs si vous
comparez par rapport à d'autres lois
antérieures et bien la formule n'existe
pas simplement c'est le hasard qui fait
que pour l'instant on n'a pas
différencier les incompatibilités entre
députés et sénateurs
or de même qu'on différencie les
inéligibilité joueurs aucune raison qui
empêche qu'on puisse différencier à la
marge mais à la marge le fait que les
accompagnent timidité ne soient pas les
mêmes et il est évident là je reprend
l'argumentation que tout à l'heure
développer de micro il est évident que
les incompatibilités doivent pas être
les mêmes que le cumul de l'interdiction
du cumul des mandats dehors pas frapper
les sénateurs que de la même manière
qu'ils frappent les députés parce
qu'effectivement ils sont les
représentants des collectivités
territoriales logique institutionnelle
finirait par une citation de mémoire
parce que j'ai pas avec moi mais dans
les débats en 85 qui sont très riches
chien dépasser nateur socialiste croit
jacques kara qui a fait une intervention
tout à fait remarquable et qui dit c'est
la nature d'institutions qui interdit le
fait qu'on impose que la provision de
cumul des mandats aux sénateurs merci de
votre attention monsieur le professeur
olivier beaud bien mes chers collègues
donc je vais maintenant donner la parole
à notre rapporteur simon sutour sont
également inscrits gaëtan gorce virginie
klès christian cointat alain richard
thani mohamed soilihi ou philippe bas
claude jeannerot
bon pierre tu n'as pas de regret non
alors j'ai 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 inscrits
c'est pas mal alors d'abord le
rapporteur monsieur simon sutour oui
merci monsieur le président en écoutant
ou madame et messieurs les professeurs
je me disais que c'était une une bonne
idée que nous avions eus d'organiser
cette table ronde des universitaires qui
nous avait été suggérée par un certain
nombre de nos collègues j'ai été j'ai
été rassuré par les propos du professeur
avril je veux dire par une partie de ses
propos puisque sur la philosophie
générale je le partage pas mais bon je
suis le rapporteur désigné par la
commission des lois mais je suis aussi
un sénateur est élu et réélu dans son
département et en écoutant un écoutant
un certain nombre d'expressions ont fini
par parent peut s'inquiéter si l'on a si
l'on n'exerce pas de demande exécutif
local
peut-on être un bon sénateur alors le
ministre de l'intérieur a fait des
statistiques et nous a indiqué que quand
même nous étions déjà 40 % 40 % des
membres du sénat ne pas exercer de
fonction exécutive locale et à ce qui me
concerne je n'exerce aucun autre mandat
que mandat de sénateur depuis mon
élection j'aurais pu en exercice mais
j'ai fait ce choix
mais j'étais rassuré par le professeur
avril qui a dit à partir du moment où on
en est lui on est élu par les élus on
devient un peu l'un d'entre eux sur le
professeur c'est ce que vous avez
indiquée et alors je voudrais rajouter
que réélu en 2008 face aux deux
présidents de deux communautés
d'agglomération
mr des deux plus grandes villes du monde
département avec plus de voix on se sent
encore plus fort mais c'est une
appréciation uniquement personnel pour
moi j'ai c'est une réalité
c'est une réalité mais qui ne vaut que
pour mon département et voilà mais bon
je voulais quand même l'indiqué parce
qu'avant données ont fini par trouver
que alors moi j'aurais plusieurs
questions à nos professeurs la première
moi je suis issu de la fonction publique
territoriale
la première c est ce que vous ne pensez
pas parce qu'on on parle comme si les
choses étaient figés comme si les
mandats avait toujours représenté la
même charge et ayant exercé dans la
fonction publique territoriale j'ai
constaté que les mandats les mandats de
maire les mandats de président de
conseil général ne sommes pas
aujourd'hui dans le temps qu'il
nécessite ce que ce que cela était il ya
40 ans par exemple
donc est ce que cette évolution dans la
charge de travail des des élus locaux ne
doit pas nous amener à avoir aussi une
évolution au niveau du non cumul des
mandats
ensuite cela a été abordé par certains
d'entre vous j'aurais aimé que l'on
revienne sur la comparaison avec
d'autres états de l'union européenne
jm de travail et je les vois que ray
dans mon rapport mais la france at-elle
encore de règle relatifs aux
incompatibilités plus ou moins strict
que la moyenne et eghezée existe-t-il en
retard français en la matière je
reviendrai aussi ça a été abordée avec
le ministre de l'intérieur qui nous a
déclaré qu'ils n'étaient pas hostiles
mais que ce n'était pas l'objet pour
l'instant est ce que la prochaine étape
de la réforme du cumul des mandats ne
doit pas être celle entre mandats locaux
et autres fonctions locales et en fait
si ce projet de loi si ces projets de
loi un projet de l'organique et projet
de l'ordinaire sont adoptées par le
parlement
quelle évolution institutionnelle selon
vous sur le rôle du parlement et le
statut des élus peut-on en attendre
voilà les questions du rapporteur ou
tout simplement du sénat membre de la
commission des lois que je suis je
voulais demander si vous souhaitiez déjà
présenté des réponses aux questions du
sénateur peut-être madame le professeur
merci monsieur le président le droit
comparé très souvent mobilisés dans le
cadre de ce débat sur la réforme du
cumul des mandats
il apparaît que la france fait figure
d'exception mais moi finalement quant
aux règles dont elle s'est dotée qu'au
regard des pratiques qui sont suivies
c'est à dire que l'on observe que dans
les démocraties comparables à la nôtre
et notamment en europe
si le cumul des mandats est pratiquée en
tous les cas la proportion de
parlementaires qui cumule est
extrêmement faible au regard des
proportions que l'on connaît en france
autrement dit la limitation ou
l'interdiction du cumul résulte à la
fois des textes mais finalement plus
encore de la pratique qui est suivie
s'agissant de la question du cumul des
mandats locaux
je crois que la législation en l'état
est satisfaisante
en tous les cas à titre personnel je ne
serai pas favorable à ce que cette
législation soit encore renforcée et je
rejoins ce que disait tout à l'heure le
professeur olivier baud pour le coup je
crois que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une logique de limitation je ne crois
pas qu'il faudrait que nous versions
dans une logique d'interdiction ou de
prohibition de tout cumul au niveau
local quant aux évolutions
institutionnelles
j'attends beaucoup de cette réforme du
cumul des mandats
cumul des mandats quant aux à
l'utilisation qui pourrait être faite
des prérogatives des parlementaires
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
guy carcassonne il avait cette formule
très célèbre selon laquelle le parlement
ne manque pas de pouvoir mais de
parlementaires pour les exercer et je
suis absolument convaincu qu'à droit
constitutionnel constants dès lors que
les parlementaires seront davantage
présents au sein de leurs assemblées
respectives qu'ils pourront évidemment
mieux se saisir des prérogatives qui
sont les leurs et j'attends d'eux cela
précisément que les parlementaires
puissent se dresser face au gouvernement
c'est à dire je suis absolument
convaincu que la moindre présence des
parlementaires dans leur assemblée du
fait de cette pratique du cumul des
mandats et bien rend la tâche facile aux
gouvernements la tâche facile au
gouvernement car en définitive ce sont
les responsables des groupes et bien
qu'ils décident en lieu et place de tous
les parlementaires et je crois que c'est
en tous les cas l'argument principal qui
devrait plaider en faveur de cette
réforme
et vous voyez ici que nos divergences
sont profondes c'est à dire que nous
faisons chacun le constat de cette
concentration des pouvoirs
nous faisons chacun le constat de cette
capture de cette caporalisation dont
souffre le parlement est bien de mon
point de vue la limitation du cumul des
manches
ça pourrait être un élément non pas la
réponse en tant que tel mais un élément
de la réponse à apporter pour équilibrer
les pouvoirs
si madame le professeur peut-être eu la
vérité que je n'ai pas dit c'est que
vous êtes obligés de nous quitter
donc j'ai trouvé une manière de vous
donner encore la parole
vous connaissez le souci de l'équilibré
auquel nous sommes tous attachés et le
la révulsion que nous avons d'ailleurs
où la caporalisation en particulier au
sénat je me permets de le dire au
passage alors eu gaëtan gorce
oui merci monsieur le président j'ai été
très sensible à ce qu'a dit le
professeur rousseau que je remercie
d'ailleurs de ne pas avoir poussé
l'indécence jusqu'à citer complètement
le président chirac par rapport à ce
qu'il a évoqué sur le fait qu'on pouvait
faire bouger les institutions par un
seul changement beaucoup plus largement
que on ne pouvait le penser
je pense effectivement que comme on l'a
fait en venant le quinquennat son
travail et du tout à l'accompagnement
juridique et les dispositifs la réforme
du cumul des mandats appelle d'autres
réflexions et d'autres changements qui
malheureusement ne sont pas dans le
débat
on attend du cumul des mandats on a dit
tout à l'heure le promu 10 l'intérieur
l'a dit d'être un élément de
modernisation de la vie politique ou
peut le considérer comme tel dans la
mesure où pour toute une série de
raisons sur lequel je l'enverrai pas on
peut considérer qu'il est mieux que les
élus se spécialise pour le cal au plan
national mais cette modernisation elle
ne se fera pas simplement par la réforme
du cumul on dit par exemple cela permet
tait vous venez de l'évoquer à nouveau
de rééquilibrer les pouvoirs entre les
parlementaires et le gouvernement
je pense que autant je ne suis pas
d'accord avec l'idée que le cumul des
mandats est un élément qui permet de
résister parce qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui que le cumul des mandats est
pratiquée que le parlement ne résiste
pas plus que cela
comparativement à d'autres pays dans
lequel le cumul des mandats n'existe pas
et où le parlement est beaucoup plus
vivant mais en revanche si le cumul des
mandats ne permet pas de résister le
fait de l'abroger ne renforcera pas non
plus la situation des parlementaires sur
leur accorde pas les moyens matériels
humains et juridiques pour exercer
complètement ses prérogatives notamment
dans le domaine du contrôle il est
frappant de voir par exemple que alors
que la constitution
reconnaît aujourd'hui à notre parlement
des pouvoirs de contrôle l'évaluation
fait partie de l'énonciation de ses
compétences on a mis en place un temps
de contrôler une semaine la difficulté
que peuvent avoir les parlementaires et
le parlement de manière plus générale à
s'en saisir
on sait que c'est la semaine la plus
pauvre du mois que celle qui est
normalement consacré au contrôle vous
avez bien ça va évoluer par la pratique
je pense qu'il faudra aller au delà
quand on est dépendant pour l' expertise
quand on est rapporteur par exemple sur
un texte économique ou un texte social
entièrement des données qui vous sont
données par le gouvernement
on n'est pas dans une situation on peut
jouer effectivement un rôle de
confrontation quand vous n'avez pour
préparer l'intervention
face à l'armada des fonctionnaires de
bercy ou du ministère de l'intérieur de
la justice que votre collaborateur et
votre bonne volonté avec votre code du
travail ou votre code des impôts vous
n'êtes pas en situation pouvoir entrer
dans un débat avec le gouvernement qui
permet face à les arguments d'autorité
de faire progresser le poids du
parlement faut donc impérativement je le
dis à notre rapporteur je viens d'être
président accompagné cette réforme de
propositions allant dans le sens d'un
renforcement des prérogatives et des
moyens concrets du parlement choisir
évidemment intéressé de connaître votre
sentiment là-dessus évident que les en
citant chez carcassonne qu'il avait à
plusieurs reprises que les pouvoirs
existe personnellement je pense qu'il
sera encore trop limité je prends un
seul exemple je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure que les rapporteur pour avis
n'est pas les mêmes pouvoirs que les
rapporteurs budgétaire des commissions
des finances freine le travail parce que
le rapporteur budget la gorge on ne peut
pas seul faire ce travail pour autant
d'ailleurs qu'ils en aient la volonté le
temps et les compétences dont ils
feraient vraiment transformer un petit
peu ces éléments pour nous permettre de
nous concentrer sur ses missions ça
c'est le premier sujet deuxième élément
de la modernisation va permettre de
renouveler le personnel politique très
sincèrement moi je suis là encore
favorables à cette loi non cumul mais si
on a la naïveté de penser qu'en mettant
en place son cumul devrait favoriser le
renouvellement se trompent radicalement
on va au contraire permettre d'entrer au
parlement des gens qui effectivement
comme le disait le professeur boudons
pas notre expérience que leur pratique
des appareils syndicaux de jeunesse ou
des partis politiques aient ce sera pas
un progrès pour les politiques
donc il faut placer les partis
politiques devant leurs responsabilités
de diversification des recrutements ce
qui se faisait assez spontanément
auparavant quand les parties avaient une
assise dans l'opinion une assise dans le
pays pour les parties les plus
conservateurs
ou une assise en mouvement ouvrier le
monde syndical pour les partis de gauche
aujourd'hui ces assises sont totalement
et rodez donc la question qui est posée
savoir comment on invite c'est là c'est
pas du domaine de la loi
c'est un débat politique au sens et
sociologique 69 du temps comme on invite
les partis politiques qui ne veulent pas
le faire a entamé ce processus de
renouvellement qui sera celui qui
permettra au renouvellement sociale et
puis enfin la question du sénat je crois
pas non plus que le cumul va changer ou
va moderniser en quoi que c'est le non
cumul en quoi que ce soit le sénat est
ce qu'il faut garder le principe d'une
spécialité comme vous l'avez fusion mais
je ne crois pas parce que ça veut dire
alors contrairement à la tradition
constitutionnelle française
le sénat a été créée on sait bien pour
amener un peu de sagesse dans les
cerveaux un peu agité de ce qui a été
élu au suffrage universel direct
au fond à l'esprit très conservateur qui
justifiait le sénat mais le sénat depuis
à regagner ses galons face au gaullisme
et dans d'autres débats notamment sur
les libertés
le sénat a vocation à rester là semblent
généralistes si on veut qu'il reste une
assemblée généralistes revanche la
modernisation 3 par le non cumul mais
par une réforme notamment de son mode de
scrutin qui pose un vrai problème
puisque la rédaction que vous avez
rappelé notre constitution indique bien
que le corps électoral doit être
majoritairement constituée d'élus locaux
ce qui freine évidemment ce
renouvellement possible et qui seraient
nécessaires sur des firmes évidemment le
le rôle du sénat dont sur ces trois
points de modernisation je ne crois pas
que le non cumul sera l'élément qui
permettra de changer
est ce que je regrette très sincèrement
c'est qu'une fois de plus je veux
trestec ce n'est qu'une fois de plus on
s'engage dans un processus sans en
mesurer tous les effets toutes les
conséquences et nécessité et c'est vrai
que si ça s'accompagne pas d'un
renforcement des pouvoirs du parlement
d'une réforme en profondeur des parties
d'une volonté de faire évoluer le sénat
il faudra évidemment aller aussi dans le
sens d'une plus grande décentralisation
on risque effectivement d'aboutir à ce
que vous évoquez c'est-à-dire à un poids
encore plus grand non pas des partis
après tous les partis moi j'aime bien
les partis mais les appareils des partis
et de l'exécutif qui va encore
s'accroître sur un parlement qui
comparativement à ce qu'on peut voir
ailleurs à l'étranger ne peut pas jouer
aujourd'hui pleinement son rôle si
gaëtan gorce virginie klès oui ma
question s'adresse ce plus
particulièrement madame benetti puisque
vous nous avez expliqué que
l'objectif qui est animé tous les
membres de la commission jospin était
essentiellement de renforcer le lien
unissant le citoyen ses représentants et
ça aboutit pour vous à la nécessité
d'interdire totalement tout cumul
donc je voudrais comprendre comment et
pourquoi cette interdiction en force
rethel le lien entre le citoyen et ses
représentants est ce que le renforcement
de ce lien est pour vous un gage
d'amélioration de l'efficacité
parlementaire et de la qualité du
travail législatif
et si oui comment et pourquoi ou alors
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt comme vous
l'avez argumenté après des raisonnements
autour de la présence des parlementaires
dans leurs chambres parlementaires
et dans ce cas là si c'est vraiment le
non cumul qui doit améliorer la présence
et d'efficacité je voudrais savoir
quelle idée ou quelles connaissances
réelles et concrètes vous avez des
missions des journées des rôles des
responsabilités qu'un conseiller
municipal d'une commune rurale de 3500
habitants par exemple exerce par rapport
à un conseiller municipal d'une ville
qui sera plus rurales deux cent mille
habitants ou encore par rapport à un
conseil général ou régional
autrement dit pour vous tous ses mandats
dans l'objectif affiché
sont ils réellement équivalent dans les
interdictions de cumul quant au
renforcement du lien entre le citoyen et
ses représentants et l'efficacité du
travail parlementaire
merci virginie klès christian cointat
oui ma première question c'est
exactement celles qui viennent déposer
virginie thèse donc je ne la poserai pas
mais j'en ai d'autres
en effet moi je si on fait une réforme
selon moi c'est pour ce soit efficace et
par exemple il faut aussi une cohérence
je vous donne un exemple je m'adresse la
a1 madame julie boulet julie benedetti
vous est farouchement contre le cumul
des mandats si j'ai bien compris et vous
dites il faut supprimer ça parce que les
parlementaires doivent se concentrer
exclusivement à leur mandat de
parlementaire mais vous ne dites rien
sur les professions qui exercent un
certain nombre de parlementaires
moi je suis beaucoup plus choqué de voir
un parlementaire qui reste avocat qui
fait énormément de travail comme avocat
qui a une clientèle importante comme
avocat qui prend beaucoup plus de temps
plutôt qu'un maire qui s'occupera des
mêmes problèmes que le par les autres
parlementaires au sénat
c'est à dire qu'il y aura une
complémentarité et une amélioration des
possibilités d'actions par le cumul des
mandats
donc là je pose cette question est ce
que vous trouvez normal qu'on ne traite
qu'une partie du problème il faut la
disponibilité je veux bien mais une
disponibilité qui ne soit pas remplacé
par ailleurs par des contraintes
également vous nous dites par exemple
pour le sénat on n'est pas obligé d'être
un élu local pour se présenter
oui enfin c'est très difficile quand
même d'être élu si on n'a pas les des
attaches avec le milieu local - voyez je
suis un câble particulier je représente
les français établis hors de france
donc il ne peut pas y avoir pour moi de
cumuls attendus
j'aurais dû étalement de téléphone
pardonnez moi je l'éteins je sais pas
comment il marche
bon alors je mets comme ça ce qui est
tout nouveau
donc je n'ai pas de possibilité de cumul
d'exil avec un exécutif local y en a pas
mais nous siégeons dans l'assemblée des
français de l'étranger comme membres de
droit et je peux vous dire que jusqu'à
présent dans le cadre de la loi actuelle
parce qu'elle a été changée mais aussi
aux paire de manches
personne à utilisateur s'il n'était pas
il n'avait pas une expérience
ce local d'élu local de responsable
local justement parce que c'est par ce
biais que l'on arrive à mieux remplir
son mandat de parlementaire et de
législateur dans le domaine où on est
vous avez dit également que si c'est pas
un élu local il y a quand même quelque
chose qui reste que nous avons changé la
limite d'âge
mc pour devenir sénateur ou se présenter
c'était 30 ans 35 ans puis 30 ans dans
la abaissé à 24
mais je veux dire que l'argument qui
étaient retenus par la commission des
lois de l'époque est présenté en séance
c'est simple c'était de dire ses 18 ans
pour l'assemblée nationale mais il faut
que un jeune qui veut se présenter au
moins la possibilité d'avoir une
expérience du local et qu'ils fassent
six ans comme le local donc 24 ans donc
il ya déjà à ce niveau là un lien on
reconnaissait la nécessité d'avoir une
expérience au niveau local pour pour se
présenter et puis je voudrais quand même
vous dire si on veut avoir des
parlementaires digne de ce nom qui ont
le courage de s'exprimer
il faut qu'il puisse être élu par eux
mêmes à celle de la première chose
or qu'est ce qui va se passer si un
maire conseiller général
un président qu en général présent on
sait rien ne veut pas se présenter
ils vont tenir actions surtout le maire
d'une grande ville dans une grande ville
c'est le maire qui va faire l'élection
et il va mettre un faire valoir
je suis désolé mais il ya ce risque
considérable qui risque de se produire
pour le sénat vous allez avoir des
élections qui se dérouleront pas du tout
pas du tout comme on peut le penser
parce que ça sera les ficelles sont
tirées par d'autres mais en revanche
c'est vrai si on se trouve au niveau du
sénat ou de l'assemblée nationale avec
ou des apparatchiks de partis ou des
faire-valoir de grands barons pour
utiliser la formule qui a été utilisée
tout à l'heure je crois que c'était le
professeur rousseau non step brothers
hbo à ce moment là on n'a pas le
résultat escompté car voyez-vous l'âme
le professeur je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec les arguments que vous
avez utilisé tous mais il me faut
arriver moi à la conclusion inverse non
pas
par la théorie mais par l'expérience
pratique que je peux avoir du parlement
donc il faut être très prudent sur les
conséquences non calculée ou non
imaginez on dit revaloriser le pouvoir
du parle du parlement je ne dirais pas
cela je dise avant que les corses sert à
revaloriser le pouvoir du parlementaire
car le parlement a des pouvoirs par la
constitution
c'est le parlementaire qui n'a pas et
d'ailleurs tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
comment pouvoir lutter contre les les
grands spécialistes des ministères des
finances avec votre pauvre assistant on
essaie de faire ce qu'on peut mais on
n'a pas la même connaissance les choses
donc il faut revaloriser les voir du
parlementaire sinon on n'arrivera pas à
farid amant progresser donc moi ce que
je reproche à cette réforme que je ne
voterai pas c'est pas d'être présenté au
contraire je trouve c'est une très bonne
chose
d'ouvrir le dialogue d'offrir une
possibilité de réfléchir et d'améliorer
les choses et je crois qu'elle va dans
le bon sens sur le plan de l'idée mais
il faut réfléchir aller plus loin faut
pas se précipiter
il faut mesurer le pour et le contre
pour qu'on n'est pas quelque chose de
totalement déséquilibrée et d'ailleurs
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure un
intervenant
les demandes du parlement doit pouvoir
se dresser contre le gouvernement c'est
quand même amusant de penser que cette
loi si elle est votée c'est parce que
justement un grand nombre de
parlementaires non ce pas se dresser
contre le gouvernement c'est exactement
l'inversé
parce que beaucoup sont contre mais il
ya tellement de pression qui n'ont pas
le courage de différents fassent alors
je vais en rester juste là simplement
pour vous dire que moi je crois que
franchement
l'essentiel c'est d'améliorer les choses
et pour l'instant c'est pas la voie que
nous avons choisie bien merci christian
cointat vous savez beaucoup votent aussi
comme ils l'entendent
ouais avec courage
bon avec courage il vote comme ils le
veulent
alors monsieur alain richard oui je nous
sommes là pour échanger les réflexions
et essayer d'apporter des sujets
d'interrogation supplémentaires et donc
merci beaucoup aux intervenants je
voudrais ajouter quelques unes qui n'ont
semblé ne pas être tout à fait présente
dans le dans les changes d'abord sur
cette question de différenciation entre
l'assemblée et le sénat
il ya une histoire et dans la réalité
d'aujourd'hui quel motif y at il pour le
bicamérisme pas du tout une spécificité
de représentation simplement la
nécessité de la double délibération
deneuve est si on a la préoccupation la
qualité la pertinence du texte
législatif de la fabrication des droits
il est manifeste que le bicamérisme
quelle que soit l'origine électives et
deux assemblées dès l'instant où elles
sont différentes il durée de mandat sont
différentes c'est à un apport de valeur
constitutionnelle en soi et il me paraît
vain de chercher d'autres motivations
ajoutons à ça que si on basculait
c'était un désaccord que j'avais avec
mon ami guy si on basculait dans une
formule qui englobe dans puisque le
couple senna assure la représentation
savait pas sa seule mission
il représente le peuple français mais
donc si on cantonne le sénat à une
représentation formelle des
collectivités territoriales ce qui est
au bout du toboggan nous le savons tous
c'est le bundesrat et d'ailleurs la
formule du professeur rousseau inclus
cette formule je ne comprends d'ailleurs
pas très bien comment elle marche quand
on perd une élection départementale est
ce qu'on perd son mandat sénatorial au
bundesrat c'est comme ça moi je me suis
trouvé le jour du de l'anniversaire
assiégée
comment dire protocolairement à côté
d'une collègue membre du bundesrat qui
avait été battu le dimanche précédant
les élections dessous l'inde dont
qu'elle voulait quitter le bundesrat
simplement parce qu'il a perdu son
mandat local
mais dans ce cas là il faut savoir que
si l'anglais il en découle naturellement
une limitation étroite des pouvoirs du
sénat qui n'aurait à se prononcer que
lorsque un projet de loi serait
pertinent par rapport au reste
habiter les collectivités territoriales
ça n'est pas du tout ce que nous
souhaitons et froissé c'est pas utile il
ya une autre observation de notre
observation qui vont sembler manquer il
ya une raison fonctionnelle est
essentielle pour le cumul celle
expertise locale peut prendre n'importe
quel des débats qui se déroulent ici
80% de l'argumentation pratiques tirés
du réel est obtenu par nos collègues à
partir de leurs pratiques locales j'ai
un souvenir fera beau il ya quelques
mois d'ici dans un débat que nous avons
d'ailleurs mal conclue sur les
conditions d'accès aux emplois d'avenir
et un débat ici au groupe auquel
j'appartiens le matin et le même débat
s'est reproduit l'après midi au bureau
national de notre parti
tous les intervenants sans aucune
exception ont tiré leurs arguments de
leurs pratiques locales à partir de
leurs responsabilités exécutives
je pense qu'il n'aurait pas pu
s'exprimer de façon pertinente sur ces
sujets s'il avait été de simples
parlementaire à un mandat local
mais sans accès à la l'exercice réel de
responsabilité à l'exercice de choix
dans des contres ajoutons et je suis
évidemment intéressé par les
observations même benetti qu'on a
entendu de nombreux soit de la part
d'autres gens éminents eux il faut il
faut faire de la science politique
il faut analyser s'il ya la moindre
chance dans la vie réelle de la société
politique française pour que une minute
de plus soit passé par le parlementaire
au parlement des instants où ils auront
perdu les mandats locaux
le premier objectif d'un être politique
dans l'ambiance concurrentiel qui a très
bien décrit professeur rousseau c'est
d'être identifiée est temps que nos
élections se feront sur une base locale
ça a évidemment plein d'inconvénients
mais ça a beaucoup moins d'inconvénients
toutes les autres formules
le premier objectif c'est identification
locale moi je suis prêt à prendre le
pari et lyon pourra le vérifier puisque
ce texte est voté
que répartition du temps dans la semaine
les parlementaires députés comme
sénateur restera rigoureusement ce
qu'elle est et que les gens qui n'ont
plus de mandat local exécutif qui se
traduit par un bénéfice
c'est vrai en termes d'identification
locales et de reconnaissance devront
consacrer au moins autant d'énergie et
le temps à se manifester en tant que
bush du coach passez moi l'expression
dans l'exercice des mandats locaux des
autres de manière à garder leur
identification locale donc ça c'est un
sujet de science politique qui permettra
un certain nombre de chercheurs de faire
la vérification de systra dit pendant ce
débat mais je veux dire la connaissance
de la vie politique française
hall politique ses locaux ceci est vrai
aussi en français tout politique et
locales entraînera en réalité une
intensification du travail je dirais
propagandistes locale des députés comme
des sénateurs simplement pour assurer
leur survie politique
donc il me semble que de ne pas voir cet
élément là dans la répartition du temps
parlementaire et dans l'axé du parlement
à plus de responsabilité c'est me
semble-t-il une vision tronquée
identiquement la sphère des successions
a été très bien développée par gaëtan
donc je ne vais pas plus loin l'idée
d'affirmer que ceci va provoquer un
appel d'air d'abord quand on regarde
statistiquement ce qu'il en est je ne
pense pas que ça va changer la
sociologie des élus nationaux des élus
des grandes collectivités mais en plus
dans toutes nos formations politiques
les conditions dans lesquelles vont se
dérouler les successions prépare en
réalité le remplacement des cumulards
qui rompt a opté par les gens qui sont
simplement leurs collaborateurs ou leurs
camarades d'organisation partisane
donc je crois vraiment que là aussi il
vaut mieux ces données quelques outils
d'évaluation pour pouvoir comparer aux
autres ce qu'on leur a dit avant et ce
qui se sera passé après enfin dernière
chose à propos de la disponibilité
combien par les personnes qu'ils ont pas
à l'âge de la retraite
combien dans les locaux titulaire d'un
executive d'une certaine importance sont
des professionnels sont des bosses
politique au sens américain
quasiment tous ont une activité
professionnelle mais pour ce qui
en n'étant pas dans les conditions les
plus difficiles comme tous les membres
du conseil d'état
on tue a comparé la situation de cumul
entre un mandat local et le parlement et
de cumul entre un mandat local une
activité professionnelle
je peux vous dire que celui qui est le
plus privatif de disponibilité c'est pas
forcément le mandat parlementaire
donc il me semble qu'il ya tout de même
un certain nombre d'angles de vision qui
n'ont pas été complètement être lui dans
ce débat et qui vont se révéler une fois
qu'on aura à appliquer ce texte dit je
remercie le professeur olivier beaud qui
a dû partir précipitamment donc il verra
dans le compte rendu que nous le
remercions très sincèrement d'être
heureux d'être venu
alors que thani mohamed soilihi sur ce
président merci également à madame et
messieurs les professeurs pour vous
exposer
je souhaite intervenir dans la
continuité des propos du professeur
avril qui a dit que n'a pas été le seul
à le dire que compte tenu du mode
d'élection des sénateurs il mérite
quelque part un traitement différent des
députés par rapport à la question du
cumul des mandats
vous avez même évoqué le fait que les
sénateurs se retrouve être parmi leurs
homologues élus des collectivités
locales
cependant il existe également comme cela
a été souligné plusieurs fois des
sénateurs qui n'ont aucun mandat local
45% si ma mémoire est bonne pour autant
pour autant sur le terrain
députés et sénateurs surtout les
sénateurs qui n'ont aucun mandat local
sont placés sur un même strict la même
pied d'égalité vis-à-vis des
collectivités locales par rapport aux
députés je m'explique il n'y a par
exemple pas d'instance ou d'institutions
locales qui regroupe obligatoirement les
sénateurs et les élus locaux puisqu'ils
font partie de la même famille il n'y en
a aucune
il n'y a pas deux d'instances locales
qui permet de les réunir obligatoirement
tout comme pour les députés et d'où la
question pour aller jusqu'au bout de la
logique est ce que le statut du sénateur
pour être spécifique ne supposerait pas
qu'il y ait cette sorte d'instance ou
d'institutions locales qui permet aux
sénateurs et aux élus locaux
de se retrouver de se réunir et
d'échanger puisque au départ c'est sur
un motif d' échanges entre ces deux
sortes d'élus que la question du statut
spécifique du sénateur et est parti en
d'autres termes sans ce lieu de
rencontre sans cet espace de rencontres
spécifiques
est ce qu'il y a vraiment une
spécificité du sénateur par rapport aux
députés merci thani mohamed soilihi de
philippe bas vous remercie monsieur le
président je ferai d'abord une remarque
de forme tout à leur professeur rousseau
s'est inspiré d'une citation qui n'a pas
voulu expliciter du président chirac et
notre collègue gore s'est inquiété de ce
que le contenu de cette situation aurait
pu être obscène je tiens à le rassurer
je ne connais aucune citation du
président chirac qui tombent sous le
coup d'une accusation d' obscénité ou
dans des sens je tenais à ce que cette
mise au point soit inscrite à foncer
vers bâle tiens je voudrais aussi lé lé
fait je voudrais
je voudrais aussi faire une autre
observation cette fois sur une question
qui a été abordé par chacun des quatre
intervenants c'est la question de savoir
si ils seraient favorables ou non à
l'avenir du sénat de différencier sur ce
point et sur ce point seulement celui de
la possibilité d'exercer une fonction
exécutive locale les règles applicables
aux députés et les règles applicables
aux sénateurs j'ai bien entendu que des
points de vue non seulement différent
mais radicalement inconciliables se sont
exprimés du coup je retiens que ce n'est
pas un argument peut-être déterminant à
ce stade de la discussion
de toute façon c'est presque une
question tactique et pour ce qui
concerne les procédures qui concerne
l'avenir du sénat chacun se souvient que
notamment avec la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
nous ne pouvons imaginer une
modification des pouvoirs du sénat
qu'avec l'accord du sénat lui-même et
par conséquent la question de savoir si
notre sort est en jeu à partir de ce pas
que nous pourrions envisager de faire
une différenciation des règles
applicables aux députés aux sénateurs à
mon avis ne se pose pas enfin ya un
domaine qui a été abordé tout à l'heure
par notre collègue alain richard et sur
lequel je ne crois pas que nos invités
se souhaite exprimer
c'est la question du statut des élus en
général quand on est élu local
aujourd'hui si on est salarié ou
fonctionnaires et qu'on est président de
son conseil général ou vice président
maire d'une commune qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'habitants adjoint au maire de
cette commune
le code du travail de statut de la
fonction publique prévoit qu'on peut
dégager de son administration de son
entreprise
25 % de son temps de travail auxquels
s'ajoutent nez
ces serments beaucoup de temps personnel
comme d'ailleurs pour tous les élus y
compris les samedis et les dimanches que
ça implique mais c'est le choix de
chacun on considère donc le mandat local
n'est pas à ce point dévorant par
rapport à l'activité professionnelle
puisque tant qu'on n'aura pas fait
évoluer cette législation c'est que le
législateur français considère qu'on
peut à la fois travailler à 75 % de son
temps dans une administration ou dans
une entreprise et exercer les fonctions
de président de conseil général ou de
maire d'une ville importante et par
conséquent la question que je me pose
c'est peut-on raisonnablement aborder
des questions aussi importantes je
dirais par le petit bout de la lorgnette
à savoir considérons simplement la
question du cumul d'une fonction
parlementaire avec une fonction
exécutive locale qui n'est qu' un cas de
figure parmi de nombreux cadres de
figure et si on regarde maintenant le
statut non pas de l'élu local mais celui
du parlementaire elle nous avons la
mémoire fraîche puisque nous en avons
discuté il y a quelques semaines le
principe pour chacun d'entre nous c'est
l'autorisation la liberté de poursuivre
son activité professionnelle
l'exception c'est l'interdiction pour
une liste de métiers qui est définie par
la loi organique je crois et qui sont
des métiers qu'on ne peut pas exercer en
étant parlementaires non pas parce que
ça prendrait trop de torts la question
ne s'est pas posée dans ces termes mais
parce que ça mettrait en cause
l'indépendance du parlementaire dans ses
votes alors nous voyons que deux bouts
de la chaîne
nous avons des fonctionnaires des
salariés tout autre professionnel tout
élu qui ne serait pas un retraité qui
sont censés avoir une activité
professionnelle pouvant couvrir 75% de
du temps de travail de n'importe quel
salarié à l'autre bout de la chaîne des
parlementaires qui ont le droit de
poursuivre des actes
évitez privé et on voudrait par ce texte
interdire un parlementaire d'abord une
fonction exécutive locale alors qu'il
pourra avoir une fonction lucrative
par ailleurs ce qui peut encourager un
certain nombre d'entre nous d'ailleurs à
s'orienter à se réorienter vers ce type
de fonction alors je voudrais pas le
sentiment de nos universitaires sur
cette question on a peur de la un champ
de discussion qui me paraît extrêmement
large et qui n'est couvert que très
partiellement par une question politique
qui est à la mode certes mais dont la
substance me paraît assez négligeable
par rapport aux questions que que
soulève ce texte latéralement et un
merci philippe bas dernier orateurs
inscrits claude jeannerot merci monsieur
le président monsieur le président je
voudrais d'abord je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier et j'y associe leur
important est d'avoir permis cette
expression pluraliste
parce que ce débat a montré on s'en
doutait quelque peu qu'il n'ya pas en la
matière comme dans bien d'autres de
vérité révélée mais surtout je voudrais
revenir devant nos intervenants sur ce
que j'ai pu tout à leur exprimer devant
le ministre au moment de son audition
j'ai je me suis permis de convoquer
comme vous l'avez fait abondamment cet
après midi notre ami guy carcassonne qui
vous l'avez noté à plusieurs reprises
était un farouche défenseur du non-cumul
mais qui en même temps
acceptez vous l'avez bien rappeler aussi
de différencier le statut du sénateur et
du député au sens où le sénateur était
l'élu des territoires et des
collectivités territoriales et j'aime
était donc l'hypothèse qu'on puisse
accepter que ces deux parlementaires
puissent être traités de manière
spécifique précisément en fonction de
leurs sources de légitimité
dans sa réponse et je veux m'attacher à
parler sous le contrôle et du président
du rapporteur et de mes collègues et ne
pas déformer la réponse du ministre le
ministre a évoqué deux arguments le
premier qui est d'ordre constitutionnel
à ses yeux cette différenciation ne
serait pas acceptée par le conseil
constitutionnel au regard même de
l'attribution identique ce cas bien
exprimer notre collègue alain richard
tout à leur regard même des attributions
identique des deux assemblées des deux
chambres et donc on ne pouvait dans ces
conditions imaginez des conditions
d'exercice pour les parlementaires qui
soit différente et un deuxième argument
qui a été apportée c'est que à supposer
même qu'on puisse s'engager dans cette
hypothèse cette hypothèse
elle conduirait tout droit defacto à
faire en sorte que progressivement le
sénat devienne une chambre croupion est
limitée à des prérogatives qui serait
par définition différente de celle de
l'assemblée nationale au regard même
c'est encore une fois cc c'est l'inversé
c'est la même réalité au regard
précisément que les parlementaires
n'auraient pas ni les mêmes contraintes
ni les mêmes statuts que pensez vous de
ce type d'argumentation 6 alors je crois
qu'il est temps maintenant de rendre la
parole à nos professeurs monsieur le
professeur pierre avril
vous prenez le un petit peu comme je
préserve
je vais d'abord et pour le postier de la
question qui m'a été posée sénateurs sur
la spécificité entre eux les sénateurs
et les parlementaires c'est une
spécificité syfy cité qui se situe au
stade des sources et que la constitution
établit elle même
puisqu'elle précise entre une fois dans
l'article 24 le sénat représente les
collectivités territoriales de la
république mais à suez sur la
représentation des collectivités les
gars mais mais possède la spécificité du
sénat mais par ailleurs et simultanément
le sénat est une assemblée parlementaire
au même titre que l'assemblée nationale
sous la seule réserve sous les seules
réserves prévues par la constitution
c'est à dire qu'il ne peut pas mettre en
cause la responsabilité du gouvernement
et qu'en revanche il ne peut pas être
dissous par conséquent il ya une
identité politique sous réserve des
différences constitutionnelles en
matière de prérogatives mais pour le
reste il s'agit évidemment des mêmes
assauts de la même nature qui est de
représenter
en effet le peuple français mais serait
dans un cas par le suffrage universel
direct soit dans l'autre cas par un
suffrage universel indirect par
conséquent soulevé le monde il est là le
fantôme d'une sorte de capitaux
diminution du sénat en soulignant sa
nature de représentants des
collectivités territoriales
c'est un argument fine qui n'a pas de
signification puisque c'est déjà écrit
dans la constitution
qu'ils représentent les collectivités
territoriales simplement c'est de tirer
les conséquences d'une mission
constitutionnelle s'est tiré les
conséquences pour ce pôle est source du
la source du sénat de ce qu'il est
précisément ce représentant et que par
conséquent on ne peut pas lui imposer la
même même régime électoral que celui des
députés mais des yoles régime électoral
n'est pas le même voilà pour cette table
ronde qui rassemblait des
constitutionnalistes et professeur de
droit sur le non cumul des mandats
une audition qui se tenait la semaine
dernière en salle clemenceau vous pouvez
toujours bien sûr voir et revoir toutes
les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité par
le monde
cet après midi à 16h30 avec le début de
la bataille sénatoriale sur le non cumul
des mandats
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires